I post a lot of different pictures to my
Instagram account i am david dot pakman
on instagram the most popular pictures
from the last week maybe not
surprisingly i talked about some of
these on the bonus show yesterday
pictures from my trip to las vegas for a
conference last week first picture that
i will show you that did really well
people really liking this me in front of
Binion's casino now this is not on the
Las Vegas Strip this is downtown Las
Vegas and I've been to Vegas 55 or so
times before this trip and I was always
just on the strip and people would tell
me oh David you know if you want to less
tourists the experience then you go to
downtown Las Vegas that's where it's
more of like a city and I went down
there and I have to tell you it seemed
like just a lower scale uh tourist
experience the fremont street experience
and even the restaurants that are like
slightly off of a Fremont Street which
is like the main street in downtown Las
Vegas it all sort of trust struck me as
as a sort of carnival uh carnival
atmosphere and vibe but just a little
bit scaled down in terms of costs and
increased grittiness compared to the
strip I don't know maybe I just didn't
get it but I in general don't fully
understand Las Vegas I find a lot of it
particularly you know that the slot
machine areas in the the strip casinos
like the win and the Bellagio it can be
depressing enough but if you want to
really see some sad gambling addiction
clear gambling addiction you go to one
of the sort of more off the beaten path
casinos off of Fremont Street in
downtown Las Vegas are the slot machine
air is there it is sad it is it is
really really a depressing experience
and also a really good experience that I
had in Las Vegas I met former NFL
running back Emmitt Smith and he was
super nice and i took a picture with him
and Emmitt Smith spoke at one of these
prior conferences that I went to and he
was a really really interesting speaker
uh nicest guy just was hanging out at
the conference this time around bullish
on the New England Patriots increasingly
into Paul
it takes just all-around good guy and a
lot of people who follow me on instagram
really liking that you can check out all
of these pictures of course and follow
me on instagram at david dot pakman
warby parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear warby parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing